it's
God
God did Jesus mention Muhammad we can
get into that where would I know about
Jesus mentioned Muhammad well your Quran
says he did so it's quoting where where
does the Quran say he mentions him 61
verse6 what does it say it says that
Jesus came with Glad Tidings right
saying that a messenger named amid will
come after
right so what's your point so if if
that's what Allah okay yes then yes if
Allah says he did they he did yes okay
so where can I find Jesus making making
this statement is it would I don't know
why you asking me for you don't know who
asking me for is this so so it's not
verifiable no no look my Paradigm or
your Paradigm I'm I'm just asking it
doesn't Paradigm though well it does
matter it doesn't matter you that
Paradigm sh are we in my Paradigm or are
we in your Paradigm well I I think we're
it's it's not about paradigms here we're
we're looking at no because we're
looking at a statement okay so I'll take
my position let me finish please go
we're looking at a statement from the
Quran that puts words in the mouth of
someone historical right when it puts
words in the mouth of someone historical
right I want to know where can I
actually find this person actually
making this claim making this statement
you want to find some piece of paper
somewhere where Jesus went around
speaking to people and mentioned
Muhammad that's what you want yeah
that's I I need the yes and this is a
reality you haven't a clue what Jesus
went around and said about anything
really person you have no evidence for
this you got no evidence for this okay
okay okay yeah you haven't you haven't
you don't you don't know you don't know
what Jesus said where he went What
miracles he did you have no reliable
sources of information for this do do do
you know where Jesus went I don't need
to I'm a Muslim mate that's what I'm
asking do you know where I'm a Muslim
I'm a Muslim why asking me why would I
care do you do you believe that he's
your Messiah do I believe he's my m
mesiah yeah no so you don't believe that
Jesus is your so so who's the messiah
messiah was Jesus the Messiah sent to
the B is to the children of Israel as he
wait wait wait a second does does not
your Quran say that Jesus is a sign for
mankind I believe Jesus is the Messiah
to the ban Israel was he a sign for
mankind for the bani Isel okay so maybe
you're unaware of this chapter 19: 21 it
says that Allah says that he made Jesus
a sign and a mercy for mankind chapter
21 verse say that Jesus is a
sign isra is he just for Israel or is he
also for okay Jesus was sent to the
children of Israel okay when he returns
at the end of days it will be For All
Mankind okay so when Jesus so when it
says that Jesus is a sign for
mankind is that only for Israel or is
that for everyone when Jesus first came
he was just for the children of Israel
when he returns he'll come to slay the
Dalal and for the and for all of man
where does your Quran say that when
Jesus first came he was only for Israel
where does your Quran say that we see we
said Isa son of is to the Ben is yeah
but where does it say only to Israel we
sent him to the B is being sent to
Israel doesn't exclude everyone else
right well if you being sent to B Israel
to the people of Israel children of
Israel yes it does that mean that you're
only for Israel well if you're sent to
the children of Israel You're not sent
to the children of the Gentiles are you
but that doesn't mean just because
you're sent to like for example was
Muhammad sent to China no Muhammad sent
for the whole of mankind he was sent to
the whole of mankind but did he leave
Arabia he didn't need to he sent
delegation to Rome to Persia to banum
and called them all to Islam got you so
he himself didn't have to go outside of
Arabia for his message to be for
everyone else right no no no no no no
there's a difference Allah says in the
Quran we sent you Muhammad as a mercy to
this is different and Muhammad peace and
acted upon that by sending a delegation
to Persia to Egypt and to Rome calling
them all to worship Allah so therefore
this is an indication and a
demonstration of his mission that he
wasn't just there for the Arabs he
called the Persians he called the
Egyptians now Jesus yeah didn't do that
Jesus was sent to the children of Israel
okay so even even according to what you
have left what even according to what
you have left the remnants The Echoes of
the life of Jesus yeah he clearly states
who he came for he clearly demonstrates
who he came for got you so all right so
let's talk about this what you just said
you said that Muhammad was For All
Mankind because and here was your
evidence is that the Quran says he's a
mercy for mankind and then you said that
Muhammad demonstrated what Allah has
said in the Quran by sending delegations
to these other nations that's what you
said so you have the claim from Allah
that proves that Muhammad is not just
for Arabia but For All Mankind and then
you have the
demonst okay in the Quran it says that
Jesus is a mercy for mankind a sign and
a mercy for mankind so he wasn't just
for Israel by that standard he was also
for the rest of the world muhad yeah
Muhammad is a final messenger there's no
more Messengers coming the new Shar is
with Muhammad the previous prophets now
have been surpassed just as Jesus
surpassed Moses and Muhammad surpassed
Jesus okay so when Allah speaks about
Muhammad he's the final messenger this
is the messenger to mankind when it's
talking about Jesus it's it's past tense
it's what's happened in history kind of
thing so we know as Muslims or we
believe as Muslims that Jesus when he
was sent had a mission to go to the
children of Israel to call them back to
worship and uh worship the god of
worship Allah and then afterwards when
they rejected him and such then when he
returns at the end of days to slay the
Antichrist yeah then he will be for
everybody obviously he's not just going
to come back for the Muslims he going to
come back for everybody okay so so that
that's that's that so you said that
Muhammad is for mankind because the
Quran says he's a mercy for mankind and
then demonstrated it by sending
delegates of of of his message and The
Message of Islam to these different
nations and different people so what you
have here is you have where Jesus
according to your Quran is sent to
Israel
but is also said to be a signed and a
mercy for
mankind so the same way that you believe
that Muhammad is for mankind the Quran
says the same thing about Jesus which is
why you should know where Jesus preached
as the Messiah what he did what was in
his message no no don't we don't need to
know these
things is he not your Messiah okay no
he's not my Messiah no okay
he's not your Messiah that's tough no
he's not where where do you get this
idea that he's not your Messiah because
he was sent to the children of Israel as
their Messiah okay who was promised the
Messiah who was promised the Messiah at
any point who was promised the Messiah
Jesus stop being Messiah second who Mah
no h this is the question does Jesus
stop being the Messiah at some point who
was promised the Messiah
everyone everyone the Gentiles too what
does it say that in Isaiah 49 what does
it say in Isaiah 49 six it says talking
about the Messiah it's too small a thing
that I should uh make you my servant to
raise up the tribes of Jacob and to
bring back the preserved of Israel but I
will also make you alike to the Gentiles
that my salvation May reach the ends of
the Earth so both Gentiles and the
Israelites are promised the Messiah so
so you're saying to me when the Jews
read their Old Testament they they
recognize a messiah that's going to be
sent to the Gentiles yes I can't believe
you say Jesus is not your Messiah that's
wild yeah he's not it's tough man okay
so 149 listen o ises unto me and hearken
ye people for far the Lord hath called
me from the womb so you think this is
Jesus being spoken about yeah of course
it's the Messiah the bowels of my mother
ha he made mention of my name and he
have made me my mouth like a sharp sword
in the shadow of his hand hath he hid me
and made me a polished shaft in his quer
have he hid me and said unto me thou art
my servant oh Israel whoa that's Jacob
no it's not who is Israel that's the
Messiah Thou Art my servant o Israel
keep reading no I'm I'm reading it thou
are my servant oh Israel So it's talking
about Jacob one second who Messiah
you're about to see who who is Israel
who is Israel I'm I'm about to show you
you have Israel you have the individual
Israel who's the messiah who represents
Israel then you have Israel the nation
who that individual say okay so let me
just read this again this is Isaiah
speaking Yeah and Heath made so so this
is what uh this is Isaiah speaking
prophetically with the Messiah right
right right right so this is this is um
him speaking Yeah listen oh Isles unto
me and hearken ye people the Lord hath
called me from the
womb okay so you think this is Jesus
speaking yeah yes okay so this is let's
imagine this is Jesus speaking from the
bowels of my mother have he me mentioned
me and Heath made me my mouth like a
sharp sword in the shadow of his hand
hath he hid me and made me a polish
shaft in his quiver hath he hid me and
said unto me thou art my servant so now
this means God has said to Jesus Thou
Art my servant oh Israel correct well
Jesus is not Israel Jesus is Israel no
Jesus is Jacob Jacob is Israel okay keep
reading we're gonna I'm G to show right
so in context it's talking about Jacob
not Israel it's not it's talking about
the Messiah who was identified as Israel
Well it can't it can't be where God is
saying to this person individual Thou
Art my servant o Israel okay just if I
promise you Hamza it all gets cleared up
if you just keep reading I promise okay
and now said the
Lord that formed me from the womb to be
his servant to bring Jac Jacob again to
him to bring who Jacob wait I thought I
thought that was
Jacob one second
H I thought that was
Jacob but look look can I can I make
something very very plain to you this
this Old Testament yeah it makes many
many mistakes errors it's well it does
it does okay okay so so so is so the
person who's Israel is supposed to bring
back Jacob so he's not Jacob himself
right okay and Jesus has never been
called Israel he's being called Israel
right there he's never been called
Israel You're assuming no no you need
him to be called Israel for this point
when has Jesus been called Israel right
there in Isaiah 49 other than other than
here where else doesn't need to be
anywhere else well it does because
you're implying it's talk about him
where it doesn't mention that's what it
says I just want to show you how bad
that argument is in chapter 61 vers do
you believe that ahed and Muhammad are
the same
person yeah no you okay so in chapter 61
vers 6 which is what we're talking about
right it says that Jesus says that Ahmed
will come after him you say that that's
Muhammad where in the Quran elsewhere is
Muhammad identified as ah oh see here's
the thing you see we don't just refer to
the Quran we have the Quan and sun isn't
it why why you why are you throwing your
arms in the air like you've just done
something this is tough this this what
I'm saying the
inconsistency what was inconsistent what
was inconsistent you you're you're
you're trying to say that there's a
problem with Jesus only being referred
to uh as Israel one time and if no time
before that or after that then that
means there's a problem no Mohammad
being identified as AED no no but
there's a difference here you see God is
telling us that this is who he's talking
about yeah where in the Quran yeah isan
is is is is where in the where I got you
where in the Quran does Allah say Ahmed
is
Muhammad that's a good
question 616 really yes and remember
when Jesus Son of Mary said oh children
of Israel I truly God's messeng to you
confirming the Torah which came before
me and giving good news of a messenger
after me whose name will be Ahmed yet
the prophet came to them with clear
proofs they said this is pure magic who
who does more wrong so there's only one
Prophet that came after Jesus which
would be Muhammad isn't
it uh well that's according to you but
where does the Quran say you say have to
that right no no no no no no the Quran
is clear that the prophet that came
after Jesus was Muhammad well see but
again you have to infer this because
nowhere in the Quran does it say that
Ahmed is Muhammad does it say does it
say that Prophet Mahammad was the the
messenger after Jesus or not uh where
does the Quran say that no does it I I
not not to my knowledge but your
knowledge is very limited when it comes
to this stuff sure so it's yours well no
no no no no
no you don't even know about your own
stuff mate I don't know why you're
trying to say I don't know I'm willing
does the Quran say that Jesus came after
list listen I don't have to make your
argument for you do I you don't know
answer you don't know what you said you
could be honest and reflect so reflect
on this does the Quran say Muhammad came
after Jesus show me that well just
showed you 616 anyway well 616 says Aid
not Muhammad one second one second so
apparently we might have two prophets
that came after Jesus somebody a
second okay so this is from the Hadith
uh Hadith yeah I didn't ask about the
Hadith according to you know the Quran
Allah says that the Quran is a detailed
explanation of everything no the Quran
also says there's many ambiguous things
which means that there's a contradiction
thank you h no no it doesn't mean it
means some verses are clear and some
things um you need people knowled to
understand right so when when there's
actually Allah and you know the irony
Allah says the mischievous ones like you
will ignore the explicit and will dig in
the ambiguous well well well let's talk
about this for a second you just prove
to me that the Quran has a contradiction
when the Quran says it's not a
contradiction it's a but hold on let me
ask you this can the Quran be a detailed
explanation of everything while at the
same time have things that are
unexplained and unclear if the Quran
says that some things are clear and some
things are ambiguous and the and the
disbelievers and Mischief Makers will
ignore the clear and will dig in the
ambiguous it's not no if you're saying
every single if Allah says everything in
the Quran you'll understand clearly
plainly that it it doesn't say that well
it it it says that everything make
things clear doesn't say let me be clear
about the verse it's chapter
12 it says that the Quran is a detailed
explanation of
everything to what huh with regards to
what what's in the Quran the Quran say
say that where does it say that yeah
chapter 12 vers
111 come on man you going to learn your
book today man in their stories there is
truly a lesson for people have reason
this message cannot be a fabrication
rather it is a confirmation of previous
Revelation a detailed explanation of all
things a guide and a Mery for people of
Faith yeah
so no it's not talking about every
single aspect of what's in the Quran
it's talking about what's happened in
the past present and what's coming in
the future exactly so the things that
the Quran mentions about the and the
future nowhere in that verse this is the
problem you see you're listening to Too
Much the Sam Shimon nowhere in that
verse nowhere in that verse does it
mention that the Quran explains
everything no okay okay let's pause here
when it says this message it's you
ignore the whole paragraph and you read
the last
chapter we're no Hamza listen we're
identifying what it's talking about when
it says this message is not a
fabrication but a confirmation of what
what is this message what is this
message we only second we only sent you
before Prophet men inspired by us from
among the people of each Society have
the deniers not travel through the land
to see what the end of those destroyed
before them and surely the Eternal home
of the hear Hereafter is far better for
those mindful of God will you not then
understand and when the messengers
despaired and their people thought the
messengers have been denied help our
help came to them at last we then saved
whoever we what are you doing I'm
stirring the pot sorry what are you
doing that for uh because I'm cooking
you what it's talking about is the Quran
correct the no
no no talk about the message from God
throughout all the previous prophets
what is confirming that came before oh
okay did you not hear what I said you
said it's the Quran now you're switching
up then bring bring up John because
bring up John because he's much more
knowledgeable on inil and all these
things yeah and we won't tag team I
won't get involved if he's just talking
or whatever but if you want to have all
the answers and all angles covered bring
up John as well in chapter 1211 do you
deny that it's talking about the Quran
it says that this this message is not a
fabrication but a confirmation of what
came before do you deny that it's
talking about the Quran right
there or do we or are we on the same
page that yes it's talking about the
Quran I I would have to look more into
it I I would say sorry just give me the
give me the verse sorry I I didn't uh
vers the vers is chapter 12 chapter 12
verse
111 this verse um yeah I mean it's it's
speaking about the Quran thank you Jeff
thank you je so Hamza
your original position was that this is
not talking about the Quran John came up
and confirmed that this was talking
about the Quran and what I said about
iir is that iath agrees that this that
the Quran is referring to itself you
didn't agree with that at first okay now
it I've changed my position okay no
worries so now you agree that it's
talking about which is what I okay but
no cut you off bro I did not cut you off
so what I'm saying is is that everything
that the Quran talks about the things
that the Quran mentions it's detailed
and explained about all of it because
that's what the Quran says Okay so the
Quran says in that verse that it is a
detailed explanation of
everything so it cannot be both it can't
be a detailed explanation of everything
while at the same time have unclear
ambiguous verses that are unexplained
can't do that that's a contrad
this goes back to this goes back to that
thing that I said to you in Iman about
the explicit and the ambiguous yeah that
we have explicit things clear and and we
have things that ambiguous we agree with
that and um sometimes we need scholar to
help us understand these things or we
need the prophet to explain these things
wait wait time out though here's the
problem yeah according to the verse who
understands the ambiguous verses uh the
prophet and people of knowledge no
potentially nope not even them not even
Muhammad not even the people of
knowledge because the Quran says in that
verse 3:7 it says None knows the meaning
except Allah it says the people of
knowledge say it's all from Allah the
absolute meaning yeah absolute not the
ab no it doesn't say absolute it says
that's the apparent
meaning and not knows its
interpretation not its full
interpretation but its interpretation
the word is not there or true is not
there no one knows its interpretation
except
Allah not even the people of knowledge
not even Muhammad only Allah knows the
meaning of these unclear verses so you
can't go to the tapir to help you you
can't go to Muhammad to help you only
Allah knows the meaning of these God to
be honest with you I mean you know we
have to hold our hands up me and Hamza
you know we're not masters of the Arabic
language you you probably better to
speak into a linguist and I'm talking
about a scholar of the Arabic language
uh when it's when it's uh talking about
the words if if you're talking about
details of translation it's the same
it's the same in uh Christian scripture
you know you can't read the English
Bible and think you've understood it
properly you you surely you have to go
to the actual word in in the original
language right so of course you can get
a gist of it but we we're all arguing
and we don't know exactly you know
ideally if you really want to get this
answered properly either with speaking
to Englishman here yeah Englishmen oh oh
we yeah I mean we're English you know
we're not master the Arabic language you
know we can read Arabic but we're not
masters of the language um so I mean if
there if you would like to speak to
someone I can try and I mean sure Hamza
knows somebody someone with better
knowledge of Arabic who can go in more
details of and show you examples okay
this word
I have Arabic speakers this is why I
know this this is why I know that the
word true or fo wasn't there maybe you
can organize one day for you know a
Muslim Arabic speaker a Christian Arabic
speaker to come and speak about this
this topic and they can give their
evidences but I don't think we're going
to do it justice this is where we are so
where the Quran says that these are
unclear verses while the Quran and and
by the way 12111 is not the only place
it's in multiple places that it says
it's fully explained and fully detailed
give examp give me another example give
me another don't prolong this this
conversation all right all right all
right wants to get onto the original
topic I know he wants to
get Avery Avery John has come to answer
your original question well I'm I'm
solidifying this and then we can move on
well you're not solid solidify
problem4 chapter 6 verse 114 that says
that the Quran is fully detailed don't
entertain it
I'm go there John doesn't want you to go
there you don't have to go there I'm
just giving you the verses no he wants
to get to the point well this is the
point you're the one you're the reason
why we're here in the first place when
we came to the Jesus is Jesus mened in
the ngel and stuff like that yeah you
because of you got us all the way here
to where you helped me present a
contradiction in the Quran okay that's
I'm just going to read this verse you
went to so 6114
say I just got to show this nonsense
just in these vers can't help it John I
will read it then but again you've
misread it it doesn't matter hold on he
said I misread it I I can't don't bite
on that don't bite on that don't bite on
that the thing
is then is it other than Allah I should
seek as judge while it is he who
revealed to you the book explained in
detail did did I read it wrong well yeah
you did you did I'll read it I'm reading
I'm reading the Quran here mate okay say
prophet should I seek a judge other than
God while he is the one who has revealed
to you the book with the truth perfectly
explained the truth yeah so that's not
even there that's not even in the it
doesn't say with the truth perfectly
explained it says that explain the
detail that's not in Arabic it it says
the Quran contains the truth the I'm
telling you the word h which is truth in
the Arabic does not exist in this verse
it's not there in the in the Quran oh
okay I'll say it again to
you it says the book look you got to
understand you it's not just taking the
word and translating it it's
understanding the context of what's
being spoken about this is how
translation works so they're so they're
so they're putting their own
interpretation this is what the Bible
does yeah like the Bible does no no
don't do that don't you do that don't
you do that can you admit that I read it
correctly one second one second when you
see something in Brackets in the Bible
what does it mean what verse is this
this is 6 verse
114 ver4 chap 6 verse 114 Hamza did I
read it
correctly not according to my Quran no
all right so your Quran has the
fabrication what's explain in detail
okay what what's explained in detail the
Quran it's Muslims they go they go
watching U Sam Shimon David Woods
averies uh this kind of stuff and they
um they get doubts and I have I've
advised Muslims stay away from these
people man they just put doubts in your
mind oh my God logic
[Music]